good morning
my name is Lorena Rodriguez I'm captain
at the sheriff's information Bureau the
order of speakers today will be Los
Angeles County Sheriff Robert Luna
Monterey Park police chief Scott Weiss
Monterey Park mayor Henry Lowe
representing the first district
supervisor Hilda Solis
congressmember Judy two
and FBI assistant director Don Elway
at the end we will be available for
questions thank you
hey first of all I thank you for your
patience I know it took us a little bit
to get out here but we're doing a lot of
very important work behind the scenes
it gives me a great sadness to be
standing before you to report such
devastating news never easy to do
something like this because it's
absolutely heartbreaking and our
thoughts condolences and prayers go out
not only to the victims their family but
this Monterey Park Community and really
the entire Community because I think
we're all going to be hurting based on
this this tragedy
on Saturday January 21st 2023 at
approximately 10 22 p.m officers from
the Monterey Monterey Park Police
Department responded to a business in
the 100 block of West Garvey Avenue in
the city of Monterey Park regarding a
shots fired call
when officers arrived at the location
they observed numerous victims and
patrons in the business parking lot
additional officers made entry into the
business and located numerous gunshot
victims Monterey Park fire department
responded to the scene and started to
treat the injured and I do want to point
out these police officers that get there
they don't hesitate they go in right
away and then our partners at the fire
department and not only the Monterey
Park fire department but many others who
came to assist the victims survivors who
needed assistance
they were at least 10 additional victims
transported to numerous local hospitals
but I do want to start off with saying
that unfortunately
when the fire department did get into
the business they did pronounce 10 of
the victims deceased
at the scene
that I just described
but the 10 additional victims were
transported to numerous local hospitals
they are listed in
various conditions from stable to
critical condition
there is a male suspect that fled the
scene and remains outstanding as of this
moment
our very preliminary description
has been described as a male Asian
and that's from the scene here in
Monterey Park
and uh it it it's taken us a while and
please be patient with us because as
we're interviewing victims and Witnesses
we've gotten different descriptions of
one suspect so when I say it's
preliminary please again be patient with
this
we are here to tell you that we are
utilizing every resource to apprehend uh
this suspect
and what we believe to be one of the
County's most heinous cases our local
state and federal law enforcement
agencies are working together to better
serve uh the residents here of Los
Angeles County and to apprehend uh this
attacker Sheriff's homicide
investigators are working diligently
with the Monterey Park Police Department
the Federal Bureau of Investigation the
California governor's office of
emergency services and numerous other
law enforcement agencies bottom line is
here we're going to use every resource
available to us because we need to get
this person off the street as soon as
possible but again
we are still in the very early stages of
this investigation and there's probably
there actually is a lot more that we
don't know than what we know at this
time
um as I said earlier the men and women
of the sheriff's department joined me in
extending our condolences uh to the
countless families affected by this
senseless shooting
and they will remain constantly on the
minds of our investigators who I see it
in their eyes they want to get this guy
and they're going to
so I also want you to know questions
that are being asked is this related to
the other event here in the city of
Monterey Park or any concerns about any
other Chinese New Year events we are
working here you see all the partners
behind me including the FBI we've been
doing threat assessments throughout the
morning are they connected honestly we
don't we don't know the answer to that
yet it may or may not be so as we look
at other events we will make sure that
we step up our presence from the Los
Angeles County Sheriff's Department we
will be in communication with other law
enforcement agencies we already have
been to make sure that security is a top
priority at any event and that's not to
indicate that we think there's a threat
there we're just taking every precaution
that we can we don't want anybody else
to to get hurt as a matter of fact I'll
be attending another Chinese New Year's
Event later on in a couple of hours and
I encourage people to go out and enjoy
the events it's it's a time from that
perspective to celebrate although this
is a very sad occasion
so I now want to introduce to you
my partner the chief of police of the
Monterey
Park Police Department
chief Scott Weiss thank you and by the
way we'll be available for questions
after everybody is done speaking thank
you
thank you
good morning everybody my name is Scott
Weiss I'm the police chief for the city
of Monterey Park
as the sheriff explained to you my
officers responded last night to this
call
we've been working with our County state
and federal Partners to
help in this investigation it's a large
investigation that will go on for many
days and perhaps many months
my concern now is the safety of the city
of Monterey Park
my officers are on duty
I brought in extra officers from home to
make sure that the community is safe
we will continue to patrol this
community and respond to anything that
happens here
we're going to remain very diligent and
we hope the community becomes closer
partners with us than this and is able
to share any information they have with
the sheriff's Homicide Bureau in the
city of Monterey Park
as the days go on we will continue to be
very diligent about protecting this city
our Lunar New Year event that was going
to occur close to where our our crime
occurred has been canceled today for
obvious reasons
and
all of us at the department all of my
officers responded all of my
professional staff
are very serious about catching this
suspect and bringing in the Justice and
that's our number one goal here
thank you
thank you Chief whis and I want to first
thank
you sure if Luna
the FBI the state emergency services and
all of the law enforcement agencies who
have been working with us for past few
hours
investigating this very tragic event
it's difficult to believe that it
happened here in Monterey Park we want
to express our condolences to the
victims and our families and moving
forward you know it is important that
we be there for them to provide services
and support they need and what will be a
time of healing in next week's months if
not years
we also want to just thank uh
everyone who has
given their support for Monterey Park
again we are uh
small community in the thing of a valley
but we're part of the larger Southern
California region family and we've been
it's been very um comforting to see the
support the output of support that's
been here for our community and our
families and again thank you so much to
our own Police Department who every day
protects this community and this is a
diverse Community um a very a difference
convenient yesterday
we kicked off our lunar celebration and
our Police Department I'm very much
aware of this diversity also has within
its ranks those who are multilingual as
well Multicultural and I want to rest
assure I want the community to be rest
assured that our police department will
continue every day to detect the safety
of everyone who lives in Monterey Park
thank you
I'm sorry um my name is Henry Lowe I am
the mayor for city of Monterey Park
thank you I'm sorry h-e-n-r-y laughing
spelled l-o thank you
good morning supervisor Hilda Solis
representing the first district first of
all I'm devastated my heart is broken to
hear that just after a very beautiful
event that many of us here attended
yesterday to hear about the loss of 10
lives mass shooting that occurred here
in Monterey Park our very own Community
as well as those 10 individuals that are
injured first of all I want to commend
the uh police department here in
Monterey Park the city of Monterey Park
for being so diligent as well as our our
Sheriff our new Shara Luna who's done
already an outstanding job but I also
want to thank the community itself
because we continue to be resilient this
is unfortunate Happening Here on the on
the day that we celebrate it's a holiday
that is so well respected and celebrated
by so many in the aapi community and
just yesterday to see hundreds of
thousands of people on the street on
Garvey to know that people could come
out after the pandemic to celebrate to
see family to see children to see our
elderly to know that this was a place of
welcoming people would come here for
many many years knowing that this was a
place of acceptance of diversity of
immigrants and it's unfortunate what
occurred we're praying for those that
lost their lives and their families and
for those that are currently in our care
and that are injured I know that at
least four of those individuals are at
our LAC USC medical trauma hospital and
I want to thank the I want to thank the
medical staff that has been there up all
night providing the services and helping
those to heal we have much more prayers
to provide for our community as you know
uh hate crime is nothing new for some
some in our community especially the
aapi community and that's why almost
three years ago the County Board of
Supervisors took action right on the
cusp of covid when we saw assaults
against people of Asian descent so we
know this is a problem and we have to
confront it but I hope today that we
remain United and that when we see
something we say something and as the
sheriff said we know that this is a a
day of a solemn moment but we also know
that the Lunar New Year means so much to
our aapi communities and this is a time
of reflection and prayer so I know I
will do whatever I can in my capacity
working with all of our our partners
here to see how we can heal but also
come up with some plans and see how we
can better serve our community so that
we can stop this hate this hate that
somehow has has taken a hold over our
communities so I pray for those families
and I know that this community is
resilient it has been it's gone through
a lot already but they remain Fierce and
they are our community they are our
Familia thank you with that
congresswoman Judy Chu
hello I'm congressmember Judy Chu and I
represent this District the 28th
congressional district
my thoughts and condolences go to the
victims of this horrific crime I can
only imagine the terror pain and anxiety
that they feel and how devastated the
families of those who were killed must
feel right now
and I can't even imagine that such a
thing would happen in this community
my thanks go to the First Responders who
came so quickly the paramedics and fire
department who were able to take care of
the injured the sheriff's uh Sheriff
Luna as well as Monterey Park police
chief whis and I appreciate the FBI
coming immediately President Biden has
been apprised of this horrific shooting
and
I hope that we can make a determination
as to whether this was a hate crime
you know this could have been so much
worse only hours earlier all of us were
together only one block away at the
Lunar New Year Festival all of us
standing right here were there and there
were thousands there
um
it is horrible that such a thing could
occur at a time of celebration for so
many in the aapi community and in the
Asian Community worldwide this is a time
to be with family
to celebrate and yet this tor uh a hole
through all of our hearts
but let me say I've lived in this city
for 37 years I was on the city council
and I was its mayor and I know how
strong Monterey Park is
Monterey Park is resilient and what I
know about the people here is that we
will get through this together
good morning I'm Don alway the assistant
director of the FBI's Los Angeles field
office and on behalf of the entire FBI
our hearts go out to the victims and
their families those that are not going
to have their loved ones come home
to greet them
the FBI is committed to providing all
the resources at our disposal to assist
the sheriff's department and the
Monterey Park Police Department
and we won't stop until everything every
lead is exhausted and justice prevails
thank you
correct
that's correct
everything's on the table we don't know
if this is specifically a hate crime
defined by law
but who walks into a dance hall
and guns down 20 people
the description we have now is of a male
Asian
does that matter I don't know I can tell
you that everything's on the table our
detectives are looking at every
possibility with our partners age range
somewhere between the age of 30 and 50.
there is a wide range and those are
things that our detectives as we're
sitting here now for the last several
hours and they we have several homicide
teams working here it's amazing when you
can pick up the phone and I have other
agencies coming what can we do to help
we want this guy off the street so we're
working very hard and we're hoping
actually we will should be putting out a
better description here in the next
several hours
uh the actual scene I have not I've been
at the crime scene but not the actual
shooting scene
that the shooter was aimed at or does it
look like it was random across the board
those are questions that we will be able
to answer just not at this time
yes
um so let me start off with the last
question regarding the city of Alhambra
we are working uh diligently with the
Alhambra Police Department uh we believe
uh that there's an incident that may be
related uh we're not quite there yet but
it's it's definitely on our radar screen
uh where a a male Asian suspect
um walked into a dance hall
and he walked in there with a firearm
and some individuals uh wrestled the
firearm away from them
and uh the that individual took off
um
now some witnesses in that area are
describing
a white cargo van
we don't know though at this time if it
is connected that white van should be
considered a man of interest at this
point again detectives looking at
multiple locations multiple Clues and I
know how hard they're working
in regards to the firearm
obviously there were multiple rounds
fired at the first location where we
have all the victims and survivors
we don't know how many rounds were fired
different weapons have been described
uh
in regards to the specific weapon we
don't believe it was an assault rifle at
this time but again that's part of the
investigation that we're looking at just
uh just to make sure and I don't want to
put out bad information
I always have hope and we have amazing
uh detectives out here the resources
that they have uh
are utilizing out here there are
multiple leads that we are following
but please keep in mind our priority
here is obviously we get to the victims
we get to the survivors uh we're going
to wrap our arms around the families
what the next top priority is to arrest
the person who did this
charge them and get them prosecuted in
the full extent of the law no matter
what the intent motive or anything was
so
that's always a possibility again very
early on in this investigation
that's a possibility when you're a good
detective you don't take anything off
the table everything's a possibility and
that could be one of them
we are still in the process of
interviewing dozens of witnesses and I'm
not going to get into detail yet about
what they said
um
look at how many cameras are in front of
me suspect could be watching right now
we do
not at this time
it absolutely could be we don't know yet
um in regards to the 10 deceased victims
uh my understanding we have five females
and five males
um in regards to their specific ages we
have not been able to identify any of
them yet we will do that with our
partners at the coroner's office uh when
the time comes
I want to see it happen within 20 to 30
minutes of the first incident that we're
here discussing
it happened after the Monterey Park
Incident
I don't have that information but there
were there were dozens of people in
there
shelter in place order for the community
we don't believe that's necessary at
this time but we will consistently
evaluate that and if we believe uh that
there's an absolute danger to the public
we're going to take every precaution
necessary we have a lot of resources out
all over the place and I don't think
we're there yet but it's always an
option in the toolbox
we don't have that specific information
yet because we have not identified them
yet but the assumption is that probably
yes but
no
uh I don't have that specific
information but we'll put that out later
our teams are doing a lot of things
right now that's one of many
Chief Weiss if you want to talk about
the initial response to the scene thank
you
so we received 9-1-1 calls starting at
10 22 in the evening
the incident as you all know is very
close to the police station we were just
wrapping up the final
shutdown of the Lunar New Year event I
had dozens of officers here
throughout the day and the evening at
the Lunar New Year event so our response
to the scene was within minutes
I don't have the exact time the initial
officers that responded
saw dozens of people exiting some were
injured some weren't and we handled them
as they came out began to triage that
and my officers put together a react
team and went inside to see if the
suspect was still in sight they were
probably entering that business within
a minute or two of responding and that's
how we've been trained and that's how we
respond to situations like this and I
want to address the shelter in place
we have a very tight Community here they
share information with us and our
partnership with our community is very
very strong
we've put out information to them about
their safety and we welcome their
questions to us I have dozens of
officers here on the street today not
just from my Agency for agencies all
over
both local County state and federal
this is a safe Community right now but
we're going to continue to be vigilant
until we take the suspect into custody
wherever they are
that's all part of the investigation
everything's on the table
uh and yeah the more people you talk to
the more information we get and our
detectives are amazing and we'll we'll
uh we'll get there
uh so if we're looking at the Alhambra
incident uh approximately 10 22. and
from the information preliminarily that
we have now we're talking about seven
between 17 minutes to 20 minutes later
the Alhambra incident occurs
yes sir Monterey Park unfortunately
occurred first
apart from the Alhambra and Monterey
Park Incident
and I don't have information about that
at this time maybe that's just some new
detail that's coming up whether it's out
there we'll clarify that
um I don't have to
the the business is well
yeah I can we pause on that on the name
of the business just out of respect for
the business owners and the victims and
survivors and then we'll work on you as
soon as we can get that out and I heard
the question over here to my right about
uh caliber
uh that's still we're still looking at
that and I would prefer not to put the
caliber out at this second just because
it's going to it may hinder what we're
trying to do and again remember our
priority is we got to get this guy in
custody and that's exactly what we plan
to do
uh not in detail at this time other than
what I described earlier that uh this
suspect walked in armed and he was
disarmed uh by a couple of individuals
so that's that's
yes
and if that changes for any reason we
will immediately notify uh our community
through all of you
it was not an assault rifle
thank you
are you speaking about the Lunar New
Year event yes were you were you there
yesterday
so thousands of people and I had dozens
of officers present I had officers
walking around and playing clothes I had
officers in uniform I had tactical
officers walking around with long guns I
had drones overhead
I had the perimeter lockdown with
barriers we did not screen people for
weapons there was probably over a
hundred thousand people present so it's
impossible to screen everybody for
weapons yesterday was a safe event
primarily because of the diligence of my
officers that were present there uh I
can't speak about the event where the
crime occurred it's a separate incident
it has no relation to the Chinese New
Year event
earlier in the day
well uh do our next update in a couple
hours hopefully
hopefully yes same location thank you
very much
Spanish will be on the side